commence à me gonfler euh on va passer
au débat du jour on va revenir sur cette
interview de Louis Boyard qui fait
énormément réagir dans un instant on
parlera bien sûr de Miss France Miss
France on a fait tout un débrief et puis
on parlera aussi de cette histoire
pierrelouis qui a dû quitter son
logement avec sa famille après avoir
posé une question sur un projet de
mosqué le témoin dans TPMP il a été
menacé de mort il sera avec nous dans un
instant pour le moment on va revenir sur
Louis Boyard qui a fait énormément
réagir une interview sur Bur FM au cours
de laquelle le député de la France
insoumise a confirmé une nouvelle fois
avoir été dealer il l'a déjà dit chez
nous et ça avait créé une polémique et
bien là il a confirmé avec une certaine
agressivité envers le journaliste qui
sera avec nous dans un instant puisque
j'adore ce jeune homme Radwan courac qui
sera avec nous juste après je parle
beaucoup avec lui sur en DM n'arrête pas
de discuter et je
lu je répond c'est même moi qui lui a
écrit tu vois vous a envoyé un message
c'est même moi qui lui écrit tu
m'enmerdes allez c'est parti regarde le
1er septembre 2021 vous déclariez de
vous-même que vous aviez déjà vendu de
la drogue que vous avez été dealer
est-ce que c'était faux c'était pour
faire du B j'ai flatté un certain
électorat ou est-ce que c'était vrai et
du coup c'est vous qui vous situez dans
le camp de la sécurité en étant ditleur
monsieur le député j'ai envie de vous
répondre premièrement d'apprendre à être
respectueux notamment parce que depuis
tout à l'heure vous arrêtez pas de
répéter pour flatter un certain élector
je trouve je trouve moi écoutez non mais
si vous êtes capable de laisser répondre
moi c'est pas compliqué je dis toujours
la vérité maintenant monsieur qu'est-ce
qui vous choque le plus d'avoir des
gamins qui en bas d'un bâtiment se
mettre à vendre de la drogue parce qu'il
y a un taux de chaômage à 30 % dans leur
quartier ou d'avoir des gens comme vous
qui viennent sur les plateaux télé
donner des leçons morale qu'est-ce qui
vous choque le plus d'avoir des gens qui
vendent de la drogue et qui tuent petit
à petit la population tout en installant
un climat d'insécurité dans certaines
zones qualifionsles de territoire perdu
de la République Monsieur permettez-moi
de vous le dire vous êtes un
privilégié c'est possible de parler
c'est discuter rond vous êtes un
privilégié vous avez la chance de
pouvoir dire ce que vous dites parce
qu'il y a des parents dans tout ça il y
a des parents qui se disent mais
pourquoi est-ce que mon petit il est en
train de s'engager à l'intérieur et ses
parents ils attendent que d'une seule
chose c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte
que leurs enfants ils prennent pas cette
voie là alors c'est incroyable ce qu'
raconte c'est fou redan tu as été
incroyable tu sais que je te suis depuis
longtemps Redwan tu es vraiment un mec
que je suis que je trouve excellent je
te trouve très bon je te l'ai dit
d'ailleurs voilà je' je t'ai écris un
mot un jour je j'ai regardé ce qu'il
faisait je lu ai dit qu'il était
excellent et on s on s'est répondu et
depuis on s'écrit pratiquement toutes
les semaines c'est vrai on s'envoie des
cœurs exactement c'est on s'envoie des
cœurs je l'adore et je trouve je trouve
[Rires]
contraement
faut pas le se voilà et et c'est vrai
que je trouve qu'il a un très gros
talent je le suis depuis longtemps et je
trouve qu'il est il est de de mieux en
mieux et c'est vrai que là là là ce que
dit Louis boya c'est incroyable quand
même de dire ça de dire vous préférez
non mais les mecs est-ce que vous êtes
choqués par après je vous montrer un
autre extrait oui oui parce que en fait
c'est presque de la justification
c'est-à-dire il dit presque il y a 30 %
de chômage dans les quartiers la seule
solution finalement c'est d'être
trafiquant de drogue c'est d'être dealer
donc ce qui est fou c'estàd que qui se
contre le fait qu'il 30 % de chage dans
les quartiers parfait mais en quelque
sorte qu'il autorise à cause de ça les
jeunes à devenir dealer c'est ahurissant
de la part d'un député quoi c'est une
offense c'est une offense pour tous les
jeunes des quartiers populaires la seule
issue que Louis Boyard leur offre
finalement c'est de leur dire les gars
il y a pas de travail aller vendre de la
drogue c'est le message subliminal de ce
que dit Louis board mais tu l'as très
bien répondu
excellent Mo su choqué par le fait qu'il
était je suis choqué aussi parle à mon
ami oui ton ami je suis choqué non mais
en fait le plus choquant je trouve c'est
son hypocrisie à Louis Boer parce que
souvenez-vous il avait dit ça sur le
plateau de TPMP il y a quelques années
et à l'époque il l'avait dit il était
presque fier de ça il disait ça un peu
pour se la raconter et là aujourd'hui
comme il est devenu député il se
retrouve dans la merde donc il est
obligé de justifier cette histoire il
essayer de trouver une espèce de cause
sociale en expliquant que les jeunes
font ça parce qu'ils ont pas le choix
assume me que tu as fait une connerie
dis que tu as fait une connerie plutôt
de trouver des justifications à de bal
moi c'est ça que j'aime pas c'est qu'il
assume pas ses propos et il remixe
l'histoire quelques années après c'est
ça que j'ai pas aimé ce qui est très
étonnant c'est qu'en préparant interview
on a on a fouillé dans les archives et
on s'est rendu compte que personne
n'était revenu avec l Boyard depuis son
élection sur les propos qu'il avait tenu
sur ce plateau euh le jour où il a
clairement dit qu'il avait été dealer
donc moi je l' je l'ai interrogé parce
que Lou Boyard à l'époque était
chroniqueur peut-être qu'il voulait
faire du buzz je sais pas JEI offrait
une issue quand même honorable de dire
oui j'étais jeune je voulais faire du
buzz et finalement je pense qu'il s'est
enfoncé et euh très sincèrement je pense
que luyard n'a jamais vendu de drogue
mais aujourd'hui il est rentré il est il
est dans un piè moi je moi je pense que
Louis boyarement je pense qu'il n'a
jamais vendu de drogue mais
qu'aujourd'hui il est dans un piège et
il ne pourra plus jamais en sortir car
soit lu sur un mytho et pour toi c'est
ça pour toi il est parti sur un mytho il
peut plus rir tu as des gens tu as des
gens tellement qui mentent en fait la la
la vérité c'est même pas le contraire de
ce qu'ils disent et luou Boyard je pense
que c'est ça il a été pris dans dans
dans son mytho il est obligé de le
continuer aujourd'hui si me dis oui j'ai
menti c'est mieux la limite c'est mieux
tu tu es à mytho ouais c'est VI bah de
toute façon c'était pas Pablo escobard
le me il a peut-être dû ramener de la
drogue une fois à ses potes vrai mais
c'est ça que moi j'aime bien les trucs
logiques et c'est ça que je comprends
pas ça fait des années qu'il a dit ça
maintenant sur ce plateau il est député
pourquoi il y aandé tu réfléchis pas à
une vraie réponse parce que tu sais
qu'un jour on va te poser cette question
on va revenir sur ce tru- et je
comprends pas pourquoi il est pas
réfléchi à quelque chose de beaucoup
plus intelligent comme a dit Guillaume
de dire bah bah oui j'ai fait une grosse
bêtise c'est une catastrophe ce que j'ai
fait et et bien sûr faut pas le faire et
là il s'enfonce dans un truc c'est radan
qui l'a dit non c'est moi c'est moi non
c'est Radouan non c'est moi c'est mon
ami Radouan qui l'a dit voilà Guillaume
salut non mais ce que ce que votre ami a
dit et est très très bien c'est oui vous
l'ami de
Cyril est-ce que vous avez dit sur le
fait qu'il assigne finalement les jeunes
de des des banlieux des cités et cetera
à à un destin unique parce qu'il
n'auraiit pas le choix c'est terrible
pour eux on nattend pas d'un député
qu'il assigne une catégorie des gens en
disant bah vous ne vous en sortirez pas
autrement que en étant dans l'illégalité
c'est assez terrible euh comme constat
pour un député de dire voilà il y a que
ça comme pour vous au lieu de dire je
vais faire en sorte que les choses
changent c'est une catastrophe parce que
moi j'ai grandi justement dans une cité
où il y avait de la drogue du matin au
soir ça dilit du matin au soir dans le
quartier et de dire ça aux gens n'allez
pas travailler si vous voyez que vous
avez la moindre difficulté aller vendre
de la drogue c'est catastrophique parce
que tu peux aussi réussir ta vie sans
vendre de la drogue en allant travailler
en te battant tous les jours en disant
voilà je suis au-dessus de ça je vais
pas tomber dans la facilité donc déjà il
fait une première erreur la deuxième
erreur c'est d'assumer de dire qu'il a
Dilé parce que je pense qu'il peut même
être encore poursuivi par la loi
aujourd'hui je sais pas mais je pense
que ça même pours par la loi et
l'exemple qu' donne c'est catastrophique
de dire voilà faites ça et moi je suis
député je le trouve très irrespectueux
avec toi à dire que tu es privilégié
comment il sait que tu es un privilégié
tu travailles sur Be FM j'ai pas
l'impression que tu sois patron du
440 croisé de dire
laiss il est pas g beaucoup moins tu GES
beaucoup Mo PRS pas 5000 balles par mois
il y autre il a une autre chose je sais
pas Louis Boyard moi Louis Boyard je
trouve tout de même que c'est un bon
orateur il a quand même ouais ouaisard
habituellement il prépare s interview là
il a été déstabilisé et euh ce dont ce
dont j'imagine c'est que Lou Boyard
s'est dit jeevens sur Bur FM c'est pass
news je pas êre je vais pas être chaé et
en fait pour ces gens-là dès qu'on est
pas d'accord avec eux une il y a une
campagne d'extrême droitisation qui
s'ouvre et on vous qualifie d'extrême
droite puisque la seule réponse de
lubyard c'est de me dire ah tu es un
facho tu es un privilégié mais il
s'attendait pas à ce qu'on lui pose
cette question sur une antenne comme
celle de Bur FM comme il était pas sur
ces news il a parlé de Bernard AR il a
dit que Bernard alors justement je l'ai
je l'ai regarde regarde Bernard auour'ui
il a beaucoup de talent sur il y a
beaucoup d'animateurs qui sont très bons
euh Louis Boyard a pointé du doigt donc
Bernard Arnou une des plus grandes
réussites financières françaises
regardez au moment où on peut avoir un
débat politique pour parler de ça vous
vous parlez de quoi vous pointez les
gens du doigt sans jamais pointer du
doigt les véritables responsables je
veux notamment vous donner l'exemple de
Bernard Arnaud qui est quelqu'un qui a
délocalisé énormément dans notre pays
qui a faité le chômage et que vous
défendez non il créit pas d'emploi il a
supprimé des emplois pourquoi pour se
faire pour aller délocaliser par exemple
en Espagne voilà c'est ça la vérité non
mais c'est V rien supprimé du tout il a
créé 15000 15000 emplois il a créé
Bernard là l'année dernière 15000 Empis
premier contributeural
deard en France il y a personne qui paye
plus d'impôts que lui en France al si
vous voulez qu'il se barre et que nous
on puisse payer les impôts qu'il paye
lui on les payera jamais nous on arvera
pas les payer donc c'est bien beau Louis
Boyard de dire Bernard Arnaud Bernard
Arnaud mais c'est c'est Bernard Arnaud
qui te paye lou Boyard si tu manges
c'est grâce à Bernard Arnaud c'est pas
grâce à à ton travail parce que tu viens
pour dire des conneries comme ça c'est
c'est 15000 emplois moi qu'on aime ou
qu'on aime pas Bernard Arnaud à moment
donné si nous autour les petits qu'on a
pas de diplôme on n pas de on n pas il
faut qu'on aille travailler pour
quelqu'un s'il y a pas des mecs comme
ber Arnaud on fait comment pour aller
travailler pour quelqu'un si nous on
peut pas entreprendre si nous on a peur
de prendre des risques si nous on n' pas
le bagage si on a pas les économies pour
prendre des risques s'il y a pas des
mecs comme Bernard on peut pas faire
tous comme
lu000 Ball à l'assemblé B demand à lu
Boyard combien a-t-il créé d'emploi car
nous on est citoyens lambda mais lu
Boyard est député il a des outils
législatives permettant de créer des
emplois aujourd'hui combien d'emplois
Louis Boyard ou ses amis les amis de
Gill
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Verdez aime qu'onime pas non
mais je sens je sens que tu vas nous
rejoindre dès début janvier toi dans la
table je le sens aussi je lui ai déjà
fait une proposition sachez-le pour le
pour le recruter en 2024 on a la réponse
on a la réponse faut que je vois avec
mon père AB il regarde la télé mais a
priori c'est bon pror on est d'accord il
nous rejoindra en J est-ce que vous le
laissez rester chez chez bien sûr restem
a plais ah oui t'inqui pas je
travaillerai jamais le matin moi mer de
pas là tu es tranquille continue FM
tranquille et si tu peux venir nous
rejoindre ça serait avec plaisir oui pas
répondre sur Bernard AR c'est pas mon
ami mais là là Louis Boyard il fait de
la politique il a le droit quand même
c'est une interview arrête avec ça
arrête
arrête de faire la politique il peut pas
dire AR ne crée pas de
travail tout ça pour pour taper sur un
gars il a le droit de de faire de la
politique on lui interdit pas de faire
de la politique mais sois honnête on te
paye pour être honnête non pas toiyard
sois honnête dis pas de conneries en
fait dis
pas en on sa déjà qu' va dire des
conneries sa
défense défense tu sais toi de jours par
semaine nous supporte 5 jours
sa je vais te dire non c'est bon si tu
le voyais que de jours par semaine nous
aussi on serait comme toi on l'aimerait
mais nous on voit on l'a 5 jours par
semaine sache-le pour nous c'est une
purge voilà si si non mais c'est une
purge oui non mais ah j'ai le droit de
parler alors oui Lage non mais c'est
comme sur Bernard arud quand il conteste
son don de 10 millions d'euros au resto
du cœur notamment où il dit c'est
0,047 % de sa fortune il aurait pu
donner plus on peut en penser ce qu'on
veut mais Louis Boyard et la France
insoumise la nupes ont le droit quand
même de faire de la politique et de dire
ce qu'ils pensent parfois c'est pas de
la
politique le fond commerce de la France
insoumise tu leur enlèves les riches tu
leur enlèves tu enlèves la défense
parfois excès des musulmans la
victimisation
systématique déjà trois causes c'est
énorme pour un parti
politique tu le rlèves mais tu
veux son
dangéfendable ils sont dangereux alors
oui il fait de la politique mais prend
compte le message il est censé
le député qui représente les jeunes il
est sur Be FM pardon qui est sans doute
écouté par par des jeunes et le message
qu'il envoie c'est moi j'ai fait des
études c'était pour faire des études que
j'ai Dilé donc déjà imagine ce que ça
fait dans l'esprit d'un d'un jeune et
ensuite c'est salud rich il y a 30 % de
chômage c'est à cause du gouvernement
donc vous pouvez daler parce que ces
salops font 30 % de chômage donc c'est
c'est un message mais catastrophique ces
gens de la LFI sont dangereux Mélenchon
dit la Poce tu ça met le feu au cité
mélange tout ben oui mais je suis désolé
c'est tes amis et c'est mes amis c'est
pas mes
amis mais tout est liéi a raison la
France à soumise dis la police je te
mett à côté de Daniel quand tu vias mais
j'adore Daniel tu mettra à côté de
Daniel bien habé aujourd'hui tu sera
peut-être
là-bas non mais la France
systématiquement pourquoi tu me regardes
en
[Rires]
rigolant ser par là-bas tu seras par
là-bas plus plus sériusement un problème
avec moi tu le dis hein on a presque la
même coupe gilvert j'ai la même
coupeadore non mais plus sérieusement
Louis Boyard Louis Boyard et ses copains
de la France insoumis systématiquement
disent la police tue déjà ça c'est
scandaleux de dire ça parce que la
police dans la République ne tue pas
elle rassure l'autre l'autre chose on
peut dire ça mais dire faut vendre de la
drogue s'il y a pas d'emploi c'est non
seulement se mettre dans le camp de ceux
qui détestent la police mais de se
mettre du côté de de ceux qui qui
perturbe l'ordre des délinqu la
délinqu mais en plus en plus c'est
dramatique parce que la France à fait
systématiquement le le procès d'extrême
droitisation mais demain dans un second
tour entre Marine Le Pen et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aujourd'hui une majorité de
Français il y a des sondages il a des
études qui le prouvent les Français ont
bien plus peur aujourd'hui de Jean-Luc
Mélanchon que de Marine Le Pen il faut
s'atterroger sur ça et ces gens
emportent une grande
responsabilité sur sur l'impopularité à
outrance de Jean-Luc Mélenchon oui gine
moi ce qui ce qui est passé un petit peu
en sourdine de ce que vous avez dit mais
moi qui m'a paru très très important
c'est que quelque part quand Louis
Boyard vient chez vous en fait il se dit
en gros moi je joue à domicile
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont tellement dans
une tactique électoraliste absolument
dégueulasse où il parlent pas au
français en fait ils parl aux Français
de confession musulmane ça fait
longtemps qu'ils font ça la LFI et en
fait comme vous vous apportez une
opposition en fait il est déconcerté et
je suis sûr qu'il va il vous devez
recevoir déjà sur vos réseau vous êtes
genre l'arabe de service le beurre de
service en fait vous êtes pas un bon un
un bon musulman ou un bon Arab parce
parce que justement vous avez pas pris
son parti ça moi ça me dégoûte et c'est
pour ça que je considère que la LFI ils
ont une responsabilité aujourd'hui dans
la séparation des Français les uns avec
les autres dans le communautarisme et
dans le fait que en fait ils cible les
gens beaucoup plus queils pensent les
protéger
oui ben
merci finalement quand il vient sur BFM
avec cette cette idée là cette idée
préconçue c'est une assignation à
résidence identitaire il dit les mec
c'est des Arabes qui vont m'interviewer
on va se parler français les mecs les
Arabes c'est bon tranquille il C TR
c'est pour nous quoi alors qu'en réalité
pas du tout non mais il a aussi une
responsabilité sur l'économie pour moi
c'est quelqu'un qui est pas du tout à la
hauteur de la fonction son son discours
sur Bernard Arnaud c'est toujours la
même chose c'est toujours il a supprimé
des emplois il a délocalisé et cetera il
sait pas comment ça fonctionne les
délocalisations il sait pas que parfois
une entreprise elle fait des choix qui
sont multifactoriels ça dépend pas
seulement le fait de délocaliser ça peut
aussi plus tard générer des emplois en
France c'est c'est c'est très compliqué
l'économie aujourd'hui mais
malheureusement les g de la France
insoumis y connaissent rien donc il
tombent systématiquement dans la
facilité avec des phrases toutes faites
du genre délocalisation il a supprimer
ceci C non mais
voilàonsabilité je dire quelque chose tu
sais les vrais amis c'est comme les
étoiles on les voit pas tout le temps
mais ils sont toujours
[Rires]
là 2 enyé je viens de penser à ça je
viens de penser à ça on a pensé la même
chose en même temps on a pensé la m on a
pensé la même chose les gars vous avez
vu cette histoire reste avec nous voir
ce qu'en pens les téléspectateurs ti on
va voir ce qu'en pense les
téléspectateurs oui 71 % voilà ben c'est
normal Louis Boyard il choque déjà voilà
il choque dès que tu dis quelque chose
ça aurait tout simplement pu ça aurait
tout simplement pu être êtes-vous
êtes-vous choqué par la France insoumise
en général car le discoursard le gars
c'est sa première émission il fait les
questions mainten
ces questions sont beaucoup plus
intéressantes que tes réponses euh merci